Paige this pot roast is tasty.
Oh, thank you. It's my mom's recipe.
Finn, can you pass the salt?
Sure.
Are you serious right now?
Seasoning my food just like white people
made it.
The recipe did come from my mother's Swedish
cookbook.
Of course, you gave her some flavorless
recipe.
I gave her a sense of style, appreciation
for fine art and education.
She still doesn't respect me.
Oh, Nadine. Nadine, Can I.
Can I.
Can I say.
Is that we all poured everything we had into
Paige.
I even did some mothering along the way.
But this is not a competition now.
"I mean, isn't it?"
Maybe a competition is exactly what this
needs to be.
Ladies and gentlemen, the challenger, Nadine
Gregory, also known as Our "Lady of
Shake.
Oh. Oh.
Nobody. And from the legendary House of
Reformation.
Karen. Oh, just as.
Jesus walks, and so does Carol.
She can do all things through Christ who
strengthens her.
Oh, damn, I forgot the.
Woman got "Schmoney Schmooze".
What up! Dad is making its presence known!
Damn right...
I was hair...
With the hairbrush and the grease laying down
and baby hairs.
Baby girl. And you get that...
Bitch!
He loved this hair with my white women.
Okay, okay. That's on me.
That's on me. I'm the first person to let
you down.
I'm sorry. Shut up and dance.
How about you dance?
(Music
playing)  Paige...
Paige...
Baby girl. If you can't forgive Nadine, how
in the world you ever
going to forgive me?
I want to be the kind of mother who teaches
my son how to forgive.
No matter what, Even if I don't think it's
possible.
And I don't know if I can do that.
Ok...
Nadine. I've said a lot of things through the
years...
But I think you're right. I have not ever
said thank you.
So... Thank you for teaching me about
Madonna.
And Worhall.
And where voguing really came from.
I'm very grateful.
Just thank you. Thank you for what you did
do.
You're welcome.
So are you going to start calling me mom now?
Let's not ruin the moment.
Thank you, baby girl.